welcome to this video round three in
countyman disc the candidates and this
video is about the game between to power
off and aronian um after two rounds both
players have got fifty percent one out
of two but while for a brownian it was a
wide right losing the first round and
winning the second topalov has played
two draws both um yeah not overly
exciting but suddenly not a bad start to
indus tournament so let's see what
happened in this game 2 pi love playing
eform he also can play d4 of course very
versatile but it seems that he intended
to put some pressure on aronian sir
double king porn this is in fact i think
remarkable about her own ians repertoire
especially against eform he really
exclusively play some the the dollar
kinghorn openings efore e5 and he
there's not even some backup line like
let's say in twenty percent of the game
he played the games he plays some
Sicilian I cannot really recall him
playing his Sicilian or the French
defense or anything maybe you find the
author blindfold game or something but
other than that he's really playing e45
exclusively okay um and he also played
it in the first round against honored ya
hear this event for h3 and would have
been interesting to see what Aronian is
doing now will he would he would he have
repeated his spawn sack or played in a
more conservative fashion yeah it didn't
materialize because to paula played a
form yeah this is the other big anti
Marshall nine
this is in fact the line that kasparov
has played most of his career because
all of I believe never allowed the
original Marshall attack with c3d 5 he
always played one of those n time
Marshall today for was his principal
choice yeah before was played this is
nowadays the main the main line in the
early days of this variation very often
Bishop d7 was played but it was
established that in a position type like
that the bishop on b7 it's just looking
at this pawn on e4 and it's not doing
black much good really before as the the
main move nowadays and it is yeah that's
the main move by farm here White has a
very principled choice he can play
slowly with the move like d3 introducing
the typical maneuvering game like this
this or maybe regroup to the kingside on
we can strike in the center immediately
and this is what kepala did in this game
he played default and aronia just
responded with d6 keeping the center and
not giving it up young this pawn on
before us of course um yeah Reverb it
has some pluses and this got some
minuses one pluses it wins space on the
queenside controlling a porn squares
it's a three and c3 are now controlled
so the night whites night cannot develop
them um disadvantage of course is that
white gains control over the important
see foursquare however
how is white going to use this glam
that's not easy at all in fact it's very
likely that black will get so much
pressure on white center that you at one
point are forced to to take on e5 and in
fact this is what to pull off did
exactly here he exchanged plates night
bd2 now we have a symmetrical position
in the center and white certainly would
like to use the C foursquare possibly
with this night Bishop c5 was played
very logical activating the bishop on a
good diagonal and this is in fact a very
important feature of this position while
this pawn advance to be four has
weakened the queenside a bit so white
can use the c-4 square the c5 square is
also firmly and legs control here's some
active here this is a good piece and
black does not have any direct weakness
or point that white can attack easily an
important feature of the position is
also that the porn on b form is always
there to capture capture something to
arrive on c3 which would open up the
beef i'll probably for blacks play and
when the porn back on c2 and not on c3
black has the important 94 counterplay
to get rid of the as often not so well
placed knight on c6 yeah a funny thing
is and something absolutely relevant on
for this game is that in the recent
championship of amenia Aronian some home
country there was a game where the black
player was around Malcolm young which is
some yeah wisdom and also a minyan grant
mercy is not so well known but
is known to be one of our of anna see
one of Aronian some yeah training
partners and did help us and in this
game the white layer was the grandmother
called terza hockey on their a5 was
played which I feel is a pretty logical
decision you fix the porn on a 60 after
Bishop c4 Queenie to you have some
pressure on this one I'm quite logical
move this is what to pile of plate
though also a move that serves a purpose
black otherwise maybe would have gone
for some activity on the on the kingside
on here after a tree aronian plate
should be seven and now 90 for getting
this Bishop actively involved and
exchanging the somewhat obstructing
knight on c6 yeah this was played and
yeah here we have reached an interesting
position early on look at the clock
tires both players played rather quickly
so we're probably in preparation and
it's funny this position also has been
reached before in a game from 1986
rather would game between blasting
billions I and Yuri resume via from
Russia in this game after Queen f3 King
edge aight was played and they agreed to
draw yeah you will never know what was
the background of this draw it feels
like in a position that somewhere
between a very little something for
white and end equality black has got
active pieces but white also enjoy some
good activity for this bishop and has
opportunities on the queenside
queena 3 is actually move that I do like
I like it better than what the ball of
plate but it's not leading to anything
great the important thing is here that
black has this pressure on the pawn on
e4 so that white cannot easily move the
night on the to end at some point yeah
well you need to develop your queen side
and you cannot do that at the moment if
you move the night here for example
black is just taking evil and um yeah
Bishop c4 was to pollow's choice the
idea will see a rather quickly a5 and
Bishop d3 this was the palace idea the
bishop is routed back to d3 where it
covers a form so that action actually
quickly you can play Knight f3 freeing
up this Bishop and attacking the bishop
on deform ya TM black has a simple
solution that aronian is going for I
place night to see Five putting pressure
on e4 and turn God asking why tell what
are you going to do next this is also a
good piece yeah why decided to to take
this Bishop takes on default and Bishop
f4 now after we piayed we see that
blacks idea was to give up the bishop am
but to have excellent pressure on the
central pawn in fact them yeah whites
needs to play very directly here
otherwise he would just lose it for no
compensation you played Queen to h5 and
Aronian played Queenie 7 this was not
the only move he had alternatives but
Queenie 7 is some
decent one of course need to cover the
night it was attacked we should be 5c 6
this looks a bit awkward but it's no
problem the point is that after Bishop
c4 black plays Bishop a6 you don't want
to play c6 and yeah let your own Bishop
stay passive on b7 for the rest of the
game of course you want to play Bishop
a6 to exchange it yet here white in fact
has a technical possibility and the
polyp went for that it's not the only
play will move white also could've
played differently I don't like the
exchange on a six this should be rather
comfortable for black but white also
could have played Bishop a2 which maybe
is even more interesting than then what
he played em it's it's hard to tell the
thing is that Bishop d6 this is what to
pile of plate it's a very direct move of
the sleep the text here here and how are
the Queen needs to take after which why
it takes I have seven this was obviously
the idea to break through one f7 King
evade you go here just take the rook so
king of eight and now a five yeah and
here we see that black only has one
playable move he cannot go to e7 for
example as why this going to play e6 and
now the threat is rookie 52 f 5 and this
is absolutely not defensible black now
something like that let's say Pusha p.m.
take
yeah like I cannot really take as this
pressure it's too much this is not a
good King position as well what this is
hanging yeah and black would resign him
it's um just like that in this position
black only has one movement this is
Queen to d7 which she played of course
yeah and here maybe here is the point
where white could have tried something
else he played e6 which is perfectly
okay but yeah maybe bishop eh taking
immediately was the more fighting option
something like that just grab on h7 but
it's it's not very likely that why does
coming anywhere near 22 pushing in this
position black has quite good pieces
Bishop here night here and he has
counterplay ideas let's say like that
for example or d3 or b3 the deep one is
especially dangerous I am not sure if
why does maybe playing with fire if he
takes on yet he played e6 yeah Queen
night x sorry of course the night takes
yeah that's not much choice of course
black takes and now we took the rook
after rook takes Queen age seven this is
probably the position that the pile of
had in mind when he played Bishop d6 and
it turns out that here it's very likely
to be ending in a draw aronian played
Queen g5 a good centralizing louth but
also a good attacking news in the long
run like my place if I
b7 or or this one with a possible attack
on g2 under the right circumstances of
course in general black's pieces are
working together so it feels unlikely
that White's assault which is mostly
based on the Queen just one okay a
powerful piece but just one piece and
the tech and that's really am unlikely
to succeed yeah it continued with F form
which I believe is what white really
should do you need to get things going
quickly to really make sure to make a
draw if you sort of make some
indifferent moves not doing much it
probably am yeah would backfire with f4
and now f5 white gets utmost activity
and it's now one of those cases where
you give it to a computer and it has 0 0
0 it's it seems to be a draw and mostly
it is due to perpetual checks d to the
toughest smooth that aronian also also
played but after the check here it's
it's just the raw King f7 and gage 5
they put this on the bots and repeated
two times and then agreed a draw yeah
can white do anything anything more if
then in this channel what can take with
check which is interesting route takes
and what is why it's supposed to do now
you don't really have a check now the
Queen cannot check but White has a
strong move here you can just take care
amazingly check and allow the the Queen
the Queen promotion check because after
that Queen a check leads to a perpetual
this is just a dead draw by my checks um
the important thing is that black cannot
go to the default check also cannot go
here check no that's white regains a
piece and yeah it's our just winning
after that like really has no way to to
avoid the draw after Chapel of those
checks check they agreed to a draw so
both players on fifty percent after this
game which is yeah of course not
brilliant but especially in case of
aronian way he lost the first game it's
still a fair result with yeah nothing
nothing being spoiled you can just still
fight for him win in this tournament and
of course you need to keep in mind the
only thing really matter in his first
place everything else in this tournament
is basically worthless you are ok you
can argue a second-place finish is
probably connected with a plus score and
some rating points there that's fine but
the real thing the only thing really
counting is a win in this tournament and
both players to Parliament Aronian they
need in the next two or three rounds
they need one or two wins otherwise it's
probably am going to be too little too
late alright a very correct I believe
game if you check it with the computed
absolutely has no really no um
substantial improvement available I
think they both played excellently well
alright I hope you enjoyed this coverage
please take note that on Sunday on the
70 the 16th some very there is no game
in clanton meniscus a rest day after
three days of playing play will only
could
new on Monday when I also be posting
coverage for those games thanks for
watching